[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y lima y continuamos nosotros en directo
América edición nocturna les comentamos
los principales hechos del día y Les
agradecemos su sintonía vamos con los
titulares
un misil de mediano alcance norcoreano
sobrevoló parte del Norte del
archipiélago japonés el lanzamiento puso
en alerta a Japón en donde fueron
evacuadas varias poblaciones y fue
convocada una reunión de urgencia del
comité de seguridad nacional lo que yo
hice bul condenaron el lanzamiento de
Corea del Norte que calificaron como un
acto de barbarie
las autoridades prorrosas reconocieron
avances de las tropas de kiev en gerson
en el que sería el mayor Progreso en esa
zona desde el inicio de la Guerra de
Ucrania el presidente celenski informó
que en varias regiones nuevos
asentamientos fueron liberados hemos
consigue perdiendo terreno en las
regiones que incorporó recientemente
y el genetista sueco es fante Paz ganó
el premio Nobel de Medicina sus
descubrimientos permitieron secuenciar
por primera vez el ADN neardental
comprender las migraciones de homínidos
prehistóricos y entender las diferencias
y herencias que guardamos con nuestros
antepasados les explicamos en esta
emisión
[Música]
Estas son las noticias de 24 y
comenzamos las autoridades de Corea del
Sur y de Japón reportaron el lanzamiento
de un misil balístico de mediano alcance
por parte de Corea del Norte El
armamento habría sobrevolado territorio
del archipiélago japonés el secretario
jefe del gabinete de Japón y condenó el
lanzamiento e Indicó que el misil
sobrevoló territorio en nipón por lo que
varias poblaciones Fueron evacuadas por
motivos de seguridad el funcionario
indicó además que fue convocada una
reunión de urgencia del comité de
seguridad nacional al tiempo que
investigarán el hecho en conjunto con el
Consejo de Seguridad desde las Naciones
Unidas el gobierno de Corea del Sur y
Estados Unidos tanto Japón como Corea
han condenado el lanzamiento mientras
que Tokio lo calificó de acto de
barbarie se trata del quinto lanzamiento
de un misil por parte de pyongyang en
los últimos días
en otras noticias vamos también a
Ucrania porque las autoridades
reprorusas se reconocieron El Avance
militares de las tropas de kiev en la
región de gerson tras haber recuperado
la localidad desde Lima en el este del
país la ofensiva se concentra ahora en
el sur del territorio con la retoma de
localidades a orillas del río níper se
trata del avance más rápido en esta zona
del país desde el inicio de la guerra
los ucranianos habrían reconquistado
territorios o como duchani ozonotopalca
entre otros el presidente de Ucrania
voló dimirselenski anunció que en las
últimas horas su ejército ha liberado
más poblaciones en varias regiones del
país
hoy el movimiento ofensivo de nuestro
ejército y todos nuestros Defensores
continuó hay nuevos asentamientos
liberados en varias regiones continúan
los combates feroces en muchas áreas del
frente
pero la perspectiva de estas
hostilidades es obvia cada vez más
ocupantes están tratando de escapar el
que tu enemigo está sufriendo cada vez
más pérdidas y cada vez Se comprende más
que Rusia cometió un error Al iniciar la
guerra contra Ucrania
otra de las recientes conquistas del
ejército ucraniano fue la Ciudad de Lima
en el este del país considerado un
importante centro logístico para las
tropas rusas las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas lograron hacer que las tropas
de Moscú se replegaran después de que
controlaban la zona desde el pasado mes
de mayo veamos
algunas victorias son estratégicamente
más importantes que otras y para el
ejército ucraniano recuperar el centro
logístico de Lima fue una victoria
significativa el presidente de Ucrania
dijo que vendrán más
a lo largo de esta semana se han
iniciado más banderas ucranianas y se
espera haya aún más en una semana
Rusia tomó el control del imán en mayo
lo que le dio a Moscú el control de un
cruce clave del río y una ruta de
suministro hacia el norte de la región
de donesk ahora expulsado en la ciudad
la victoria de Ucrania es para el jefe
de la otan una prueba de la capacidad de
kiev para desalojar las fuerzas rusas
hemos visto que han sido capaces de
tomar una nueva ciudad y que demuestran
que los ucranianos están progresando son
capaces de hacer retroceder a las
fuerzas rusas por su coraje por su
valentía por sus habilidades Pero por
supuesto también por las armas avanzadas
que están proporcionando los Estados
Unidos y otros aliados a pesar que el
Ministerio de defensa de admitió que
Estaba sacando tropas del área de Lima
por temor a ser rodeados los soldados
rusos continúan tratando de evitar que
los ucranianos avancen hacia Severo
niessky en la sesión informativa del
domingo el ejército ruso no mencionó al
imán pero promocionó la destrucción de
los depósitos de misiles ucranianos
siete depósitos de armamento de
artillería y municiones fueron
destruidos también se destruyó un radar
de guía del sistema de misiles de
defensa aérea s-300 el tiempo también ha
sido crucial las tropas rusas fueron
expulsadas del imán justo después de que
Vladimir Putin declarara cuatro regiones
del este de Ucrania como territorio ruso
siendo una derrota punzante para Moscú
en otras noticias el gobierno británico
liderado por listeros o dio marcha atrás
a su decisión de instaurar una rebaja
fiscal para los más ricos la propuesta
había provocado protestas en diferentes
sectores políticos incluso entre sus
filas trolls se presentó esta
disposición como parte de un paquete de
medidas con el que pretendía impulsar el
crecimiento económico del país en un
momento en que preocupa el desempeño de
la nación en materia económica y
financiera
bajar los impuestos a los más ricos una
propuesta que ha provocado protestas
incluso dentro de las filas del partido
conservador forzada y coaccionada la
primera ministra británica que lleva un
mes en el cargo ha dado marcha atrás o
mejor dicho dejo que lo hiciera
suministro de finanzas
hablamos con nuestros selectores y nos
pareció que la idea de eliminar el tipo
impositivo del 45% un día del paquete de
medidas tan sólido que propusimos sobre
los recortes Fiscales para la gente en
general Así que decidimos no seguir
adelante con ello la propuesta de re los
impuestos a los más ricos era una de las
medidas del plan del gobierno presentado
el 23 de septiembre el objetivo era
hacer frente al aumento del coste de la
vida y estimular el crecimiento pero su
financiación y su impacto económico no
sean cuantificado completamente como
resultado la libra ha caído a su nivel
más bajo de la historia y los tipos de
interés de los préstamos públicos han
subido esto se suma al ya preocupante
contexto económico y social recesión
inflación por encima del 10%, explosión
de las facturas de la energía y un
gobierno que sobre todo quiere salvar su
paquete de medidas el crecimiento de
nuestra economía Debería ser nuestra
principal misión con este plan planeamos
un crecimiento del
2,5%. lo hemos hecho en el pasado y
podemos llegar a ese nivel Incluso si
nos enfrentamos a una volatibilidad
extrema en los mercados mundiales Tan
pronto como asumió responsabilidades el
equipo del strass tuvo que hacer frente
a grandes manifestaciones que se
multiplican en diferentes sectores y la
popularidad el nuevo gobierno
actualmente está en caída libre cambio
de tema el presidente estadounidense Joe
biden llegó a Puerto Rico para evaluar
los daños causados por el huracán Fiona
que tocó tierra en la isla del pasado 19
de septiembre los habitantes se
reclamaron la falta de apoyo del
gobierno estadounidense cuando han sido
afectados por desastres naturales en el
pasado el mandatario también visitará el
estado de Florida este miércoles y se
espera que anuncie ayudas para hacer
frente a la devastación que dejó el
huracán
informe de Manuela Cano
no los olvidamos Ese es el mensaje que
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
Busca mandar en su visita Puerto Rico
después de más de dos semanas de que el
huracán a tocar a la isla el mandatario
llegó al suelo el territorio libre
asociado para evaluar los daños y
anunciar ayudas por 60 millones de
dólares
venimos aquí en persona para demostrar
que estamos con ustedes todo Estados
Unidos está con ustedes mientras me
reciben se recuperan y se reconstruyen
Confío en que podemos hacer todo lo que
usted quiera gobernador y estoy
comprometido con esta isla
la visita de biden llega 5 años después
del huracán María quedó bastó la isla en
una tragedia que según muchos
puertorriqueños no tuvo la respuesta
adecuada por parte del entonces
administración de Donald Trump el miedo
de una situación similar se repite ahora
con Fiona que causó la muerte al menos
25 personas y dejó a la isla sin
electricidad unos daños que Siguen sin
revertirse por completo a un cerca del
10% sigue sin energía
al lado de Fiona Ian los daños del
huracán que tocó Florida como categoría
4 siguen apareciendo los equipos de
rescate han reportado que han visitado
45.000 hogares y negocios en las áreas
afectadas y los fallecidos ya son casi
un centenar las labores de rescate y de
restauración de la energía continúan en
este momento en todo el estado 95% de
los clientes tienen electricidad
hasta ahora hemos tenido más de 1900
rescates con los equipos de la unidad de
búsqueda y rescate que han ido puerta a
Puerta de 25 diferentes edificaciones
Florida espera la llegada de baile el
miércoles una en la que el mandatario
evaluará los daños en primera persona y
se espera que anuncien nuevas medidas
hacia la reconstrucción del Estado
el Instituto Carolina
de medicina o fisiología 2022 avance
pavo un genetista sueco que ha dedicado
su vida a investigar la evolución
genética de la especie humana sus
descubrimientos permitieron secuenciar
por primera vez el ADN neardental
comprender las migraciones de los
homínidos prehistóricos y entender las
diferencias con nuestros antepasados el
científico desarrollo la primera técnica
para secuenciar ADN de decenas de miles
de años de antigüedad algo que se creía
imposible por el daño del paso del
tiempo en 2010 secuencia por primera vez
un ADN de un neandertal vamos a
conversar sobre este tema con Harry
pachajoa Él es médico especialista en
genética y médica y doctor en genética
directores del centro de investigaciones
de anomalías congénitas y enfermedades
raras de la universidad y Ceci en Cali
también es genetista de la fundación
Valle del Lili Harry gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y qué tan adelante
nos llevan los descubrimientos de pavo
que lograremos conocer de nosotros
mismos a partir de esta secuenciación
del ADN neandertal
Buenas noches Muchas gracias por la
invitación Yo creo que la labor que está
desarrollando este investigador nos ha
abierto un mundo de expectativas Pues
solamente como para poner en contexto el
proyecto genoma humano digamos la
decodificación de todo el genoma del ser
humano como tal fue en el 2003 él hizo
el proyecto genoma neandertales del 2009
y posteriormente descubrió una nueva una
nueva especie digamos el denisovan en el
2010 todo esto ha permitido entender un
poco más como Cómo ha ocurrido el
poblamiento digamos en la en la Tierra
no se conocía muy bien digamos esto para
nosotros los seres humanos en la
actualidad para que nos iba a servir
pero por ejemplo Ha logrado la
identificación de genes relacionados con
el desarrollo cerebral que provienen
digamos de ese de ese de ese flujo flujo
genético como la denominado en la
investigación es entre el Homo Sapiens
con el delantal entre el Homo Sapiens
con el
porque esas tres especies esas tres
especies convivieron en en común y
nosotros somos producto de toda esa
herencia Pues también logro identificar
que teníamos como un tronco único para
estas tres y esto permitido por ejemplo
los últimos años y ahora con lo del
covid es saber que hay una respuesta
inmune puede estar regulado por género
relacionados con esa herencia neandertal
Bueno yo creo que nos abre un mundo de
expectativas justamente sobre eso quería
preguntarle porque gracias a Paul ya
sabemos que los neandertales y los Homo
Sapiens se reprodujeron mientras que
coexistieron como usted lo describía
cuál es esa herencia genética que
llevamos actualmente a partir de esas
uniones se habla de ese impacto que
usted mencionaba de nuestro sistema
inmune por ejemplo
entonces yo te coloco un ejemplo el Homo
sapien como tal aparece así como 300.000
años hasta la actualidad el Metal
probablemente entre el 400.000 hasta
hace 30.000 años
Tuvo unos años en común pero por ejemplo
la expresión de genes como el tkt l1 y
el Nova 1 que son importantes para el
ser humano del desarrollo
de la corteza cerebral
provenía precisamente desde el altar es
decir que esa Esa esa combinación o ese
flujo de genes
permitió tener un desarrollo cerebral
como lo tenemos actualmente Así mismo
también con la respuesta inmune Y eso sí
mencionar las otras probablemente como
el deniso van con otros genes Y
probablemente tiene que haber otras
especies que jugaron un papel importante
para poder
tenernos a nosotros como como seres
humanos hoy día como nos conocemos
rápidamente para cerrar hablemos de esa
importancia de conocer nuestro rastro en
el mundo a partir de las migraciones
Bueno ese tronco único hace 800 mil años
digamos el Homo sapien como está 300.000
años hasta la actualidad pero el Homo
sapien que sale de África migra por toda
Europa por Asia Estrecho de Bering llega
a América esto nos permite esto nos
permite entender el poblamiento y
también permite entender la ocurrencia
de la enfermedad genéticas en algunas
poblaciones Entonces yo creo que aquí se
marca como un nuevo Punto de partida es
un reconocimiento a una persona
extraordinaria porque no solamente es
genetista el viene de las humanidades
viene de aprender la citología viene a
aprender la ciencia viene a aprender
cáncer Entonces esto nos va a ayudar
mucho para el entendimiento de la salud
humana
de esta manera llegamos al final es de
directo América de edición nocturna por
esta noche pero quédense con nosotros a
malbett nos Explica en África 7 Días
como acontece el nuevo golpe de estado
en burkina faso buenas noches
[Música]